a gt's most talked about moments from
last night's semifinals and Simon's plea
for Garth Brooks help hey guys Danny
director here there's only a couple
weeks left before America's Got Talent
crown through next million-dollar act
and last night the competition was as
fierce as Tyra Banks looking like she
just washed up on shore I went on such a
dip and you have no idea but that's
because it's the AGT semi-finals baby
and here were the night's standouts
pediatric nurse Michael caterers cover
of the Miley Cyrus song when I look at
you got a standing ovation from the
judges
[Music]
and move Simon Cowell to make this
shoutout Garth Brooks got if you're
watching the show please write Michael a
song for the final if he makes it into
the final I just had this feeling about
yeah you two have a game I already
thought that this was like idea but like
all my dreams and but that is even more
of a dream to have a song written by
Garth Rhodes by him as you know what I
was thinking about this before who would
be the the top person in the world to
write the michael and there was only one
god if there's anyone to get Garth
Brooks attention it's probably really
that's right ETA Ichi please it is your
mission together Scarborough alright I'm
not joking we actually did reach out to
Garth and his team but they didn't get
back to us in time but dammit Garth
right the man of song after face Simon
again next week don't make me look like
a fool love you mean it
alright another fan favorite is Mary
trapeze artist duo transcend and after
redeeming themselves from their stunt
gone wrong this time they upped the ante
and the danger
[Music]
[Applause]
[Applause]
just when you thought duo transcend
couldn't outdo themselves on a GT
tonight they added flames more flames
and rollerskates
you guys this time you brought more
flames you brought more fire and also
added some rollerskates I mean how did
it feel up there were you were there any
nerves going into it this time because
we've never combined the two acts
together and we've never seen it done
and we're like you know what it could be
a disaster but we're gonna go for it do
you take that into consideration when
you're choreographing this like we need
spots where we can catch our breath
after yeah we we actually there was a
few tricks and skating that we that we
were moved because we needed time to get
our our bearings back you know and so
I've been hanging upside down yeah yeah
so it's really disorienting to go from
trapeze being upside down and then going
right set up and spinning in a circle
real fast yeah so it took it took a bit
to adjust to that feeling right but
we're so glad that we did it yeah and
we're so glad that the judges loved it
cuz it paid off it did it really did it
like made us feel so much better I feel
better about this and I did even our
last performance because this was this
was much more of a challenge for us even
though getting that blindfold drop from
last last round was so important for us
achieving what we did tonight was a huge
challenge with the next level at what
point did you guys realize alright we're
gonna do rollerskates we've got to do
something crazy and step it out at what
point did that happen are they just
gonna keep doing trapeze and I'm like
you know what you just wait and see
not me I'm like that's enough for me you
know that's a lot of work so argue we've
met your son Jax today I mean what did
you think of mom and dad's performance
tonight
you know what he's too so he's still
kind of in those stages where like he
loves anything that that is exciting and
visual it's fun it's fun to have him the
audience it's super exciting to perform
for him let's practice every day he sees
yeah so that everyone else he claps
didn't leave on stage and you'd like I
think I've seen this before mom do you
think you have a future Chevy's artists
on your hands you know what if he wants
if he wants to be a part of it we would
love to have any hit it'd be so fun have
a little trio with three of them oh okay
take that act on the road huh they say
they saved the best for last here on a
GT and tonight that went to Tyra's
golden buzzers
[Music]
let's talk about your golden buzzer
closing out the night I mean they're
gonna be wants to remember after this
night how do you feel about it I just
feel that I am so happy they told me
about that building buzzer changed their
lives and I just hope that they win this
damn thing they really want it don't
think they really really wanted to
deserve it and like you know don't come
from the most polished backgrounds all
of them so this would be totally
life-changing I love are you just in the
background like hyping them up right
before they hit the stage no I'm
stretching this I'm not like bending
them we're doing yoga doing Tai Chi
together or whatever Tara is doing to
help them it's working all right we'll
find out who makes it on to the finals
with America's Got Talent
airs tonight on NBC until then if you
need a little refresher on some of these
acts make sure to watch our AGT playlist
on e t--'s youtube channel and i'll see
you guys soon bye